اصيب الدلال بانفجار قنبله عنقوديه من
مخلفات القصف في محيط قريه عرب سعيد بريف
ادلب بعد ان ظنتها لعبه كباقي العاب
الاطفال
مخلفات الحرب والذخائر غير المنفجره باتت
تشكل خطرا على حياه الكبار والصغار في
المنطقه حيث وثقت فرق الدفاع المدني منذ
بدايه العام الجاري مقتل اربعه اطفال
ورجلين واصابه 16 شخصا بينهم عشره اطفال
وثلاث نساء اصيبوا بانفجارات ذخائر غير
منفجره بمناطق متفرقه من شمال غرب سوريا
للاسف اليوم بعد 12 عام من الحرب ما زلنا
عن نواجه خطر مخلفات الحرب كميه الاصابات
والوفيات اصبحت مخيفه جدا بسبب انفجار
الذخائر الغير منفجر معظم الاصابات لما
تكون ضمن الاراضي الزراعيه ومعامل جمع
الخرده لازم اليوم نوقف عمليه جمع الذخائر
وخلطها بالخرطه
جمع الذخائر ومخلفات الحرب لتفكيكها
وبيعها يعد خطرا يهدد الكثير من العاملين
في هذا المجال الذين اجبرتهم ظروف الحياه
الصعبه لتحمل مخاطر هذا العمل وهي مخاطر
اكبر بكثير من مردوده المادي طبعا نحن
بلشنا بها المهنه هاي من بدايه الحرب تمام
من ضغوطات الحياه وقساوه الحياه وهالامور
هاي صار معنا انفجارات صار معنا تفجير
خسرنا اخسرنا شابين طبعا بدايه الاحزان
بدايه
الاحداثوا معنا
لقينا قساوه كتير بهالمجال هذا تعمل فرق
الدفاع المدني على عمليات البحث والازاله
لذخائر غير منفجره في عموم مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا محاولين الحد من مخاطرها من خلال
فرق مدربه ومجهزه للتعامل مع هذا الخطر
ووقت فرق الدفاع الم دني
435 عمليه ازاله لذخائر منذ بدايه العام
الجاري جميع الفرق العامله في الدفاع
المدني التعامل مع الدخار والتخلص منها هي
فرق مختصه وخاضعه لتدريبات مكثفه لكيفيه
التعاون مع الذخائر يحاول المختصون من فرق
الدفاع المدني الحد من خطر مخلفات الحرب
التي لم تتمكن فرقهم من ازالتها بعد من
خلال حملات توعيه مكثفه للتعريف بخطر هذه
المخلفات على المجتمع محمد الاشقر العربيه
محافظه ادلب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات